And we've had some reports from Congo,
Nigeria, and even Syria, although it's
very mixed reporting on Syria, and I'm
not sure how true it is there, but but I
wondered, yeah, if you could explain
what's going on.
>> Sure. So, you know, the p the
persecution of Christians, and it really
dove tales wonderfully with what we're
talking about because it's again, it's
part of the continuum. Uh the
persecution of Christians by Muslims has
always been there from the very
beginning because most of Muslim lands
are in Christian territory. Um, and
that's why so many of them ended up
converting to Islam. and [snorts] you
have small minorities and that's why
they disappeared in some areas. So the
cops for example who used you know the
word Coptic for example just to give you
an idea of how infused with Christianity
is you know the word Egyptian that's the
Greek word which is iiptos and um when
the Arab conquerors of Egypt came they
took the word for native Egyptian Igtos
but they just took the middle syllable
gipped and that became transliterated
into cop for us. So it just means
Egyptian but it means Christian because
all the Egyptians were Christians. So
cough means Christian and Egyptian.
Anyway, um so they went from being the
majority or almost 100% to now they're
10% because of 14 centuries of
discrimination and you know sporadic
persecution which is well documented by
the way. Anyone who's interesting can
get a book called a sword a sword over
the Nile which is uh it's not my book
but it's really great because it's based
on the primary sources of what happened
um to the Christians of Egypt. Anyway,
what's interesting is if you fast
forward, so okay, during the attacks on
Christians of the Middle East, Egypt,
Syria, everywhere it was again attacks
on churches, attacks on their persons,
of course, extorting money from them as
a form of Jiza tribute, enslaving their
women and children, etc. That's still
going on, okay? And it's in all the
Islamic worlds to different degrees. U
maybe you've heard of a group called
Open Doors. Um, okay. Okay. So, it's a
humanitarian Christian international
organization which has been around for
decades and every c every year they
publish a report. It's called the world
watch list and it ranks the 50 worst
nations to be a Christian where
Christians are most persecuted. And I
look I write about it every year and you
know it habitually 37 38 of the 50 are
Muslim nations. And I mean that to me
talk about telling right? It's like
almost every Muslim nation there is a
foreign a kind of Christian persecution.
Some are worse than others. Okay now we
can go to Africa. That's the worst
subsaharan Africa that according to a
lot of uh human rights groups there's a
genocide in Nigeria and and I follow it
closely and I think every week I have to
read about dozens of Christians being
killed by Muslims. Uh and of course the
media they they tell you no no this is a
this is about climate you know change
one group is being pushed out and
they're attacking another group.
>> Oh they actually do that?
>> Well actually they do that actually.
Yeah. And they don't tell you that the
ones being pushed out are all Muslims
and the ones being killed are all
Christians. Okay. No, they actually do
that.
>> So what what's happening then in
Nigeria?
>> Uh you have Muslim groups. First you had
the terrorist group called Boo Haram,
which means Western education is a sin.
And all they've been doing is attacking
and killing Christians. But now you have
what's called the fani. They're
herdsmen, okay? who live and and c with
they graze their cattle and they're
attacking the Christians who are
sedentry okay and they're just
butchering and killing them and taking
over their land and of course also
engaging in dur destroying their
churches and other the hallmarks of
attacks on Christianity that emphasize
that there's an ideological component
but if you talk to the professionals and
the media is has nothing to do with
religion it literally it's climate
change because the pastoral fani are
being pushed out And they're just they
need more land. So they attack these.
But for some reason they only attack
Christians uh never Muslim sedentry
areas.
>> Yeah. And what how exactly does climate
change forced them to kill?
>> Exactly.
>> So where's the motivation?
>> No. A lot of I remember the I think it
was the Irish president who came out and
made a big scene about no this is
climate change. Don't talk about Islam.
It's Islam means peace. And this was
like a year ago. And uh it's like
>> mostly peaceful climate change.
>> Yeah. And then the next day, you know,
Muslims attack a church in Nigeria and
kill like 50 people and and all of a
sudden that too is not about religion.
Um I mean they I've really followed this
and the the the little the acrobatics
they play to just make you think this
isn't about religion are amazing even
though it's so obvious about I once
quoted a nun a black nun from Nigeria
who's like you know it's it's hard for
us not to believe this is about religion
when they're dressed in black screaming
Allah Akbar and break the cross you know
and you tell me it's about climate
change. So, so that's Nigeria, but in
subsaharan
>> in Nigeria, do we have a sense of the
death to talk?
>> Um, I've seen various reports and it
apparently got really, really bad
starting around 2009. Um, and has been
going on and off, but I would say maybe
70,000.
Yeah. Just butchered.
>> And what has the Christian response been
to that?
>> The Nigerian Christian or
>> Nigerian or the greater Christian?
greater Christian response is it's not
happening, you know, and there's nothing
to see here. You know, black lives
apparently only matter if they're not
Christian, you know, it's it's really
it's it's one of those things where if
it was the opposite, if this was, let's
say, Muslims being killed by Christians,
this would be on the news nonstop,
everyone would know about it, you know.
But such as it is, uh, and and again,
>> why why do you think that the the
Christians don't care about this? I
mean, I think to a great degree a lot of
them don't know. So, they're basically
just misled by the media that they
trust. You know, Fox News isn't going to
talk about this either, right? So, for
whatever reason, this isn't a topic for
them.
>> But, I'd have hoped that like the Church
of England or the leaders of the
churches who do know about it, they
absolutely know about it. would be every
single day, every single church service,
they'd be proud.
>> But, you know, also a lot of these
churches don't want to antagonize
Muslims and they're more excited and
more proud about holding hands with a
Muslim imam and showing their wonderful,
you know, ecumenicism, reach out. So, a
lot of them don't want to Pope Francis,
you know, he puts he writes encyclicals
about this and that. How about
Christians being butchered left and
right, you know, um any word on that?
Nope. We don't want to talk. So again,
you have to understand that amongst
Christians of all denominations, there's
this political correctness, this need to
like make Muslims look good and you
know, etc., etc. So they don't want to
talk about it. It's uh if you talk about
Christian persecution, you totally
overthrow the narrative that they've
been trying to build because you know,
if you talk about Muslims attacking
Israel, okay, it kind of makes sense
because they're the underdog. They're
angry. They're fighting back. Okay? But
if you look at the Muslim world and you
realize Muslims are dominant there and
they're persecuting their tiny
minorities simply because of religious
differences because they're not Muslims,
then you start realizing, okay, so
Muslims are just u [laughter]
intolerant and uh maybe this isn't about
what's happening in Israel. Maybe this
is just something among them. Um so that
I've noticed and I've been following
this and writing about it a lot. Muslim
persecution of Christians has been one
of those most no topics. We don't want
to we don't want to go there cuz it's
because there's no rationale to it.
Muslims attack Israel. Muslim bomb
western cities. Oh, they have
grievances. Oh, this. Oh, that. But if
you find it's an institutionalized
discrimination and persecution of
minorities simply because they're not
Muslim. How do you get around that?
>> Well, the way you get around it is you
don't talk about it.
>> And you put that back to that Quran that
you cited earlier about the people of
the book. And
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. That's that's one of
the verses. Uh yeah. Fight the people of
the book. Quran uh 9:29, but there's
others in the hadith telling you how to
treat Christians. If you see a Christian
or Jew, you have to push them against
the wall. Don't say salam, don't say
hello uh to Christians and Jews. Um all
sorts of things. You have to hate them
even though you have to live with them,
etc., etc. So, yeah, it all traces back
to these scriptural injunctions.